riders ready watch the gate this is BMX
bicycle racing it's basically an
acceleration contest if not endurance
and so the whole thing is it's like hard
drag racing and those get going really
fast hold the lead and then carry it on
through to to to to the end so what you
do is you get three opportunities to
advance the call Moto's
moto one moto2 moto3 some other
organizations have different rules but
I'm talking about ABA American bicycle
Association you have eight lanes on a
track and to advance into the next round
you had to win one of the Moto's okay
that means so you get into the first
moto and usually a very good rider would
win it he or she would sit down and then
this other seven riders we're going to
the second moto
then whoever won that would sit down
then there'd be a third moto for the
third rider then those three riders
would advance into the next level of
competition at a big meeting could be
eighth finals quarterfinals semifinals
but you advanced okay so the big issue
is to get out of the first round it's
like in basketball getting past the
first round of the playoffs
well there's eight riders and so you
have eight lanes and lane eight is
always called the one that is farthest
from where you turn so if you turn left
this would be lane eight if you turn
right this would be lady outside like
it's the outside lane you have to travel
further if all riders were equally
talented you wouldn't win how to bleed
eight I mean if they all fell down or if
something happened somebody nearly but
in general assuming that all riders are
equally talented the chances of winning
a Dulaney are very slim a lot of people
watching might have seen the Olympic
Games or running races where we see
staggered lanes or we could have a tool
to see a line like an angled start like
BMX racing doesn't compensate in this
way now if you could keep people in
their lanes you know like you
in track you say you have to stay for
the first lap in your lane but of course
you don't
and what happens if you ever try to do
that these really aggressive riders okay
with just in other words if somebody was
in front and they saw somebody starting
to pass him they would just move in
front of them and knock them down so you
can't give someone an opportunity to be
in front of somebody else because
they'll move it out and it's gone so
that doesn't work
years and years ago when my son started
racing everybody just rushed the gate
and just now notice that Lane eight
outside is no good and lane one inside
it's too easy to get somebody to cut you
off or somebody to get boxed in so the
good lanes are usually two three four
maybe in an extreme case five but but
let's say three and four in the early
days people would rush to the track when
they said we're going to okay let's
start the racing and then run it get
into three or four so then they said no
that's not fair so then they said it
okay what we're going to do is what call
these range at random something you'd
have a deck of cards okay and they'd
have eight and you just pull the card
and that was your length or they haven't
earned with balls in it and you pull one
and stuff and at least that was fair in
the sense that you know you had equally
likely chance to get any one of the
lengths so that's how it went on for
years and years and years at the start
of each moto remember we have three
motors so you have a random draws a
starter motor one random draw two
starter motor two random God start mode
3 now the problem was that with that
random draw there's a reasonably likely
chance that you could pull 3/8 and if
you are off somewhere like my son once
was we were in Shreveport Louisiana and
he proved 3/8 well he'd rode gallantly
ok
but he still didn't qualify into the
next round so he thought he was unlucky
the curse of lane eight the curse of
Lane eight
so I said we need a better system we
need one where my son can't get three
eights or two states at a seven a
colleague of mine who's a statistician
we just started talking and said let's
fix this
okay we're mathematicians we're hotshots
let's fix this system there were two
breakthroughs okay to breakthrough the
first breakthrough was
that's not a sign a lane independently
three times let's instead give you a
triple and your triple would have three
numbers in the example let's say it had
one five eight that means you get Lane 1
in in the first moto Lane five in a
second at eight and here's another major
breakthrough instead of working
mathematically with the numbers of the
lanes like one and two and three we
decided to work with the priorities okay
one meant the best Lane two men to
second with and eight and the worst that
has mathematical content so we put
mathematical meaning into it by saying
priorities they're well ordered they're
numbered there's a one it means
something an eight it means something
those two breakthroughs triples and
priorities that's kind of subjective so
what you do is you ask a bunch of good
riders which one is their most desiring
and there's almost total agreement
almost if you had to say anything it
almost always be lane three sometimes
before okay maybe but it was almost the
same which it was the worst everybody
would say eight so maybe there's some
fuzziness in between but almost all the
good riders would tell you the same
thing so that day so that was not a
problem
so did you do this was it was like some
kind of survey oh yeah I did every time
I did it with my son and his friends and
they thought that the you know sometimes
there was a right answer and a wrong
answer of course there wasn't so now I
had to build a mathematical model that
says how am I going to come up with the
very best set of eight triples there
will be the fairest and then run it on
the computer with an algorithm to give
us the best so we did and what we did is
we try to say look everybody should have
the same you know if you if you summed
up priorities like maybe the priorities
like one five eight as I said before and
you sum them you know you're going to
get 14 well maybe everybody should have
the same sum of priorities that would be
a good fair discard but you can't do
that they're all going to be 13 or 14 so
you now you start playing mathematical
games about saying a model so soon you
start to realize that the best solution
is going to have four 13s and four
fourteen so that's already
the data back a lot you see it's already
saying oh now I don't have to search
everything and so with that constraint
that four are going to be 13 4 we're
going to be 14 you start to do a search
how comes a situation where you get
these optimal eight triples in less than
one second
we found 7,000 solutions okay so so yeah
but that's too many solutions so that's
not bad let's grow you could no no no no
no no no you say good things but look in
in mathematics and physics when you find
too many solutions that means you didn't
put enough information into your
mathematical model the most beautiful
mathematics is there exists one solution
see and that's why in life we say ah
there's one perfect marriage partner
there's one perfect house there's one
perfect would I grant you that there's
not but anyway we like that so I spent
time with a student and we said look if
you're an average rider the third moto
is more important than the first and the
second and I'm going to tell you why
because there's always some hotshot and
hit and hit this hotshot is going to
ruin the first race then the second
hotshot will win the second so they know
in the third race though not in the
third race so now you want to optimize
your chances in the third race that's
when you want the problem that's when
you want the prime lane so I said let's
wait these sums so that they're not all
equal and that a good lane in the third
moto is worth more than a good lane and
we put a little tiny bit of waiting on
there and very simple I mean like the
waiting was that maybe in the third
motor there's only six riders so we
waited it by maybe eight over six or
something that gave us the unique
solution so we ended up with our optimal
solution I say any reasonable
mathematician or intelligent person once
you told them look think of priorities
and think of triples that come up with
our system that's what I say professor
yeah only problem I seems your system is
the priorities are very subjective and
and Billy the BMXer might prefer lane
one because
he's good on tight corners and Sally
might like the outside lane because she
doesn't like crashes and like different
riders might have different priorities
and not like your Bowl system I mean of
course you're right but you're really
fine-tuning at a level that doesn't
exist okay I mean the bulk of the riders
so yeah so there's somebody who has some
particularly well they're going to lose
I'm going to pay a price okay but you're
doing this for the bulk of the things
and and granted there's always going to
be some kind of a Chris suit like that
okay and and and indeed you can say that
but it's it's not a it's not a concern
okay and then you say we're going to do
this for the bulk of the riders it's
going to take care of bulk of the
problems
and cents I wasn't trying to save the
world I was trying to use mathematics in
something that would improve the quality
of my local life while my son was racing
okay and we did that and and so to me it
was a validation of mathematics okay how
people or mathematics is not useful
well mathematical thinking and the
mathematics allowed me to do something
very interesting